هذا وقال الرئيس الاوكرانيس كان روسيا شنت
امس هجوما صاروخيا هائلا على المدن
الاوكرانيه اضاف
ات الجويه
الاكثر من 20 صاروخ روسيا وان بلاده تحتاج
الى الاسلحه الموجوده في مخازن شركائها
لوقف ما سماها الارهاب الروسي
بالاسلحه جنه روسيا هجوما صاروخيا هائلا
اخر على المدن الاوكرانيه في مدينه دنبرو
وانقذنا عشرات الاشخاص بينهم اطفال نتيجه
ضربه روسيه دمرت مبنى سكنيا من تسعه طوابق
لسوء الحظ قائمه الموتى تتزايد كل ساعه
المطلوب تلك الاسلحه الموجوده في مخازن
شركائنا والتي ينتظرها جنودنا اي مفاوضات
او وقت يمر لا يمكن ان يوقف الارهابيين
الذين يقتلون الشعبنا بالصواريخ
وبالطائرات بدون طيار التي تم شرائها في
ايران العالم كله يعرف كيف يمكن ان يوقف
اولئك الذين يزرعون الموت